hey what's up my name's samuel leeds in
this video i wanted to talk about the
difference
between wholesaling real estate or
property
and deal packaging now this is something
that all the time i get asked usually by
people from the united states of america
they don't understand in the united
states of america
what deal packaging is they think it's
wholesaling
but wholesaling is a completely
different thing i mean when i went to
philadelphia on my financial freedom
challenge and i was in new york
i got cheating spit spit out in new york
but that's another story
um they just didn't get it so let me
explain wholesaling
okay wholesaling and this is not
something that i i've ever really done
to be honest it's cool it's neat it's
fine
it's when you agree to buy a property at
a set price
let's say you agree to buy the property
at 80 000 pounds but you know
that it's worth at least 90 000 pounds
so you secure it at 80 but then you take
it under contract
and you go find a buyer and you find
someone to buy it for
90 000 pounds and then you sell it to
that person
you're the middle person and then you
keep the profit the difference minus
costs
and then that's how they make their
money that's what wholesalers do
that's cool i have no issues with that
at all but it's not deal packaging
deal packaging in my opinion is actually
a lot lot better i've
sold hundreds of deals packaging and
selling deals and it's actually what
made me a millionaire so what's deal
packaging deal packaging is when you
find a property
you agree to buy it at a price a fixed
price you don't take it under contract
you're not even particularly the
middleman all you do is you then you
then agree to buy the price and then you
package it up as a really good
investment opportunity
you then pass on the opportunity to the
investor
and you say hey i got a deal i agreed to
buy it for 90 grand it's worth 100 grand
and i've got a management company nearby
and it's a really good return on
investment
here's the due diligence i've done on
the area and all i want is a
fee a finders fee an introducer's fee
of 2 000 pounds you then package the
deal and you pass on the opportunity
but before you pass on the opportunity
you're going to take your money
you're going to take your 2 000 pounds
so you're getting paid up front
and then you pass the deal on and then
your job
is done now of course you have terms and
conditions in place
which say what happens if the if the
deal falls through or if
you know you're gonna have to have that
in place but you find an opportunity
pass the opportunity on take your money
move
on to the next deal that's deal
packaging that's the difference between
deal packaging and wholesaling
i'd love to know what you guys think is
better and i'd love to know what
experience you've had in deal packaging
doing wholesaling so please let me know
your thoughts in the comments
what do you like more wholesaling or
deal packaging
what have you experienced let me know in
the comments also if you've got other
questions or you're confused about the
language or
what the terminology means for property
investing or being a property
entrepreneur
let me know in the comments as well as i
do a video every single day
and the reason i keep doing these videos
is because i keep making money in
property
people keep asking me stuff so rather
than having to repeat myself over and
over and over i just bang it out on a
youtube video so if you enjoy my channel
and you find it helpful
please do me a big favor smash the like
button subscribe to the youtube channel
turn the notification bell on and i look
forward to seeing you next time